الخلافات بين قوات الدعم السريع وقياده
الجيش طفت الى السطح منذ بدا الحديث عن
دمج هذه القوات في جيش موحد ففساد السي من
يونيو عام
2021 اعلن نحو ان الحديث عن دمج قوات
الدعم السريع في الجيش يمكن ان يفكك البلد
تطورت الخلافات الى ان صرح حميتي في اغسطس
الماضي بان اجراءات البرهان التي حل
بموجبها مجلس السياده في 2021 فشلت وان
السودان اصبح بحال اسوا في الخامس من
ديسمبر وبتوقيع الاتفاق الايطالي المؤسسي
للفتره الانتقاليه عاد الخلاف بقوه بين
الطرفين في مساله دمج قوات الدعم السريع
تاكد ذلك عندما انسحب ممثلوا الجيش من
ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري نهايه مارس
الماضي وقبيل ساعات من جلستها الختاميه
لعدم شمول توصيتها اي جدوله زمنيه لعمليه
الدمج في الثاني عشر من الشهر الجاري بدات
قوات الدعم السريع بالانتشار في العاصمه
في مناطق بالعاصمه الخرطوم وبعض المدن دون
علم قياده الجيش او التنسيقي معها